all right Tyrone okay second video same
thing I thought we did in the last video
very great I would just say you know
like hey I wasn't looking at you the
whole time but I could feel you like
loosen up a little bit man loosen up a
little bit you look a little bit
recording I'm not recording so it's just
off camera this is off camera this is
not happening
yeah just loose another that was tight
something tells me you're gonna lie
different when I have someone don't cam
with me you know do you think we're
having a real conversation are we doing
the bit because a camera's totally been
on but you caught on to the fact I was
being sarcastic
oh no I thought the camera was off oh
yes whoa well now it just got real I
would do not mean to offend you or make
you feel like I was actually putting you
down
that was all just part of the bit and I
am sorry that I thought you realized
take it I let you hurt my tone okay woo
cuz you're doing like it's an honor to
be here with you right now it's alright
it's an honor
hi guys I'm Greg she's Tyrone you heard
of me and heard of him
god dammit split M night Shyamalan do
you like in my show he's the one that
did uh I see dead people
yeah that's the name was a big success
after that like everybody's mad at him
cuz nothing else was the hit not true
right not everything unbreakable had a
good following signs decent the village
stuff a gate like if you go on rotten
tomatoes you could just watch the
decline of all the reviews it's like
this ascending order like whoa mr. B
starts off like here and then you just
look like okay like it says in Kane
could be better but the last movie he
did was the visit that mockumentary
movie about you know those kids who
visit their grandparents oh I guess we
just saw about you guys I'm good
yeah there's surprisingly good has
presently fun too because M night
Shyamalan haven't taken himself so
seriously in like ruining a lot of
really strong potential Phillips and
then when I did the visit I was like oh
this is cool he has like a big sense of
fun here I don't reminds me of how like
Zack Snyder's throwing in a lot of humor
for Justice League right now because a
lot of people were like you're a little
too serious yeah I was fine with what
you did Zack yeah I know damn right
posing polar opposite
that's all right it's okay Center is
still friends when you start your
channel I'm just warning you you're not
gonna get more followers than me because
of that appendages oh yeah you're not
gonna get more call Batman V Superman
was a great you don't want to say that
you don't you telling you all right if
you want YouTube success you can't get
away with sustaining your own opinions
all right so so we're gonna watch this
trailer called split right back
one thing about reaction videos Tyrone
they don't want you to take too long
it's the REO yeah those are complaining
okay just go to the reactor
creepy looking girl sex trade I was
important the only cheese we have is if
all three of us go crazy on this guy
develop where the Train don't worry he's
not allowed to touch you that's right he
knows what you're here for listens to me
my name is Edwin 923 identities they
live in Kevin's body who are you I'll
tell on you
only the clever ones an individual with
multiple personalities can change their
body chemistry was there fun someone's
coming for you the beasts there's a
ducted us and he's going to kill me
were meant for something the gory
Oh God the hold you understand now the
beasts I'm just gonna thank the people
and him do awful things to you he's done
awful things for people and you'll do
awful things to you
oh man so we're gonna get to see his
range here I doubt it
they all look the same all the
personalities the interesting dad that
was create it this totally surprised me
I expect it to be what it was that is a
nice surprise
it's really misleading at first and then
now it really makes you wonder like
where's this going exactly but I want to
find out because this is it's like 23
different personalities in there I would
like to see what 23 different
personalities are trying to master in
the end exactly either yeah maybe maybe
that's what the lease is dominant yeah I
mean that's one of these days yeah I
have 23 different personalities you
ready for this 1000 we're ready y'all
gonna be accents that's all I'm gonna do
okay all right um this is am I out these
are my vocal warm-ups that I do and I
switch personalities every time
I'm trying not to laugh at myself so
much I'm like I find myself so funny oh
I do hope it you want to die - no it'll
pour into the Caribbean personality
number one hello would you like a spot
to take listen a would you love that
kind of crap that there you that's
really good to you all right son
we are from Ireland we're gonna go down
to the Bob's and drink of stupid [ __ ]
there I got a little warm up here all
right all right so Maya from Scotland I
like to wear a kilt in my favorite
movies Braveheart
doing pretty good for a man I'm from
Mexico si I gotta kick your [ __ ] ass
OOP that five that's five
ah okay LOC Rita you are so wonderfully
sexy your detour is yellow as my you are
a where's that six six [ __ ] okay I'm
gonna get this co-invest you will I am
from Russia in Russia we have greatest
box of Ivan Drago right yes they are so
this is the world dude look you go boy
you like tinfoil Adrian good they do too
okay
hey that's our personality that's an
impression alright uh I'm gonna exit
yeah it's still an accent um okay
a-all right where I leave off hey bro
from Armenia bro
would you like to smoke hookah same
thing as a Russian I'm not really a
different personality uh okay okay
sometimes I embody a different care
for movies it's the weirdest formative
problem never see that yes it is
hey knocks I can go truthfully go into
it's what he is I'm committee with there
and that's a big winner my father was a
drinker and a fiend one night he comes
home waving a knife around drugs he must
have friends yeah and then we sometimes
I share personalities with Tyrone walls
but the boss was not spawn whoa whoa hey
if you want to hear a few look and then
we're done I promise and it's game
boring all right okay this is young Al
Pacino Dog Day Afternoon sound
what are you doing Sal I told you to rob
the bank Sal you're not supposed to
shoot the hostages Sal that's none of
the wines I'm just make that up
modern-day Al Pacino hello
I am Al Pacino today I'm gonna sit here
with Tyrone Magnus ha ha do reactions
yo hey Tyrone you are good funny man yo
ah ah yo and literally it pretty
guttural whine is not a minute okay okay
Oh obviously my dr. Phil impression you
are one ugly woman my Boston um [ __ ]
[ __ ]
haha
hahaha oh yeah yeah and that's it I'm
done
wait my classic Johnny Depp Jimmy dude I
did not know that he could do that many
impressions I'm actually impressed Thank
You Terry
I did all my warm-ups before you showed
up today so I could be like here and be
like okay now I know what I'm living
with dude I've seen this show like 16
times already know the whole thing I'm
not reaction I've been preparing for
preparing you guys thought I was only
want to do impressions look at that see
I have talent to you guys all right I
have some talent yup he's not just big
jokes I wouldn't need a heaven to take
jokes for a while come on have it really
I haven't really ensure you haven't
alluded having a lid to penis pearl very
long really okay I'm sorry
still used to the old view sorry it's
okay left no impression with me I liked
right right you know what I feel like
the most people lid to okay let's move
on okay I'm high I went like 15
impressions that made a single dick
reference and you know what got no
credit for that no credit what happens
good you're a funny guy for your dick
jokes yeah oh I gave you that's what my
channels makalah we gave him props for
his his impression in his range thank
you I I didn't know he could do that I
really did he should also look into
doing voiceovers I think I should watch
see you like my voice when I'm doing
like a camera talking a little bit
higher up here but imagine if you called
my hotline one 800 grit no panties
tonight a lot more digits than you'd
expect but trust me it's worth it that
turned you always make sure you hit them
and the business inquiry inbox so it
gets your email well I have a Community
Guidelines strike that does not allow me
to post videos longer than 15 minutes
the review of the actual trailer will be
on another video okay yeah
like cuz this this is this is the first
time here I'm glad you're here Fortin
for me to do my one-man show I'm glad I
was here too I know more about his
talents now I really haven't impressed
and surprised Oh Greg Alba has rings yes
thank you Thank You Fenny other channel
subscriber the region's tinyint how many
would you to plug me a little bit I
don't that's not a penis joke no oh I
would never plug another man will never
say okay
no tie rapper hat channel maybe you've
heard of it maybe you haven't yes he has
about a third of the subs I have
it's embarrassing really that's why I'm
here Berra Singh yeah claps he's trying
to get more subs cuz he is running super
low um this is grabber bass see if you
need subscribers the smart thing to do
is go on someone's channel who has more
subs than us don't bring them on yours
go on their channel and that you gather
some of their subs yes you don't put
them on your channel absolutely no
that's why Tyrone's on this channel
today because he's trying to gather some
subs because his channel that's true in
the pooper